so i'm like coach i'm not missing a mech
gala for a browns game oh what's up boys
we talking about wives saint laurent
sorry the receiver club is for smart and
classy positions
yeah i don't think the seahawks even
have it tied in i'll show them smart and
classy yo guys
some faces need beards we have to prove
we're not just dumb linemen with hands
yeah
it's time to start tight end university
where trials go
all right recruits sing it with me
[Music]
so how long do we have to be stuck
together
[Music]
i haven't been this emotional since
wrestlemania 19. fundraisers so we can
buy more backwards hats what's up we're
here to save your party ah no offense
noah can't let you in
there's nothing we can do technically
it's an accredited university next
description of gatsby is just so
inconsistent perhaps nick carraway
is unreliable narrator oh
you versus us the annual touchdown dance
you win the crown and we'll go the way
of the fullback and just disappear come
with us kid oh i'm a tight end
welcome to the touchdown dance oof is
this what cam is doing these days show
us that swag
oh this dude's intense as hell
oh it's like a two-person scene you all
right come on killer trap it's all up to
you it's not gucci it's gucci tyrique is
cheetah and travis is your brother jason
[ __ ] you catching is for pretty boys all
right the call of the tight end whoa
whoa
[Music]
i'd like to announce that i'm officially
stepping down as head coach of the
jacksonville jaguars i'll be going back
to college to become the coach of tight
end university not a power five school
what i'd like to announce my total and
complete commitment to the jacksonville
jaguars go
duvall